et c'est pour changer en cette période
de fêtes et de repas de famille on
parlait de cannibalisme la fin qui fait
chavirer la raison au point qu l'homme
on vient à dévorer l'homme et quant à
l'ogre celui qui dévorait les petits
enfants il n'a pas existé que dans les
légendes la faim qui pousse les hommes à
manger les hommes
ça s'est passé ici en europe lors des
grandes famines comme le rappelait
l'ethnologue claude lévi strauss dans
cette émission en 1982 on a rien à
manger et pour survivre
bon on mange des êtres humains
ça existait à plusieurs reprises et ça
existait encore tout récemment dans
notre propre société
quel rapport avec les fêtes de fin
d'année le rapport c'est lui saint
nicolas chaque année le 6 décembre
il donne des cadeaux aux enfants sages
une tradition encore vivace dans le nord
et dans l'est de la france
et ce jour-là garçons et filles seront
nombreux à fredonner ces jolies chansons
populaires
au champ centre
gilles a lâché j'ai bougé à une comptine
pour enfant mais aux paroles qui n'ont
rien de temps écoutons un peu mieux
[Musique]
l'histoire de saint nicolas s'est donc
celle d'un boucher sans scrupules qui
attire trois enfants chez lui
les découpes pour en faire du genre ont
salé et qui seront ressuscités sept ans
plus tard par le fameux saint-nicolas
lui même averti par les anges
[Musique]
une légende bien sûr mais qui repose sur
une vérité la famine en europe qui a
poussé à l'anthropophagie le tabou
ultime et les témoignages sont très
rares mais au 11e siècle
raoul glaber un moine copiste à
consigner des témoignages terrifiant le
voyageur assailli sur la route succombé
sous les coups de ses agresseurs ses
membres étaient déchirés grillées au feu
et dévoré et pire encore si on peut
faire pire
ce passage qui rappelle cruellement les
contes et légendes qu'on raconte à nos
enfants
quelques autres présentaient à des
enfants un oeuf ou une pomme pour les
attirer à l'écart il les immoler à
l'enfant le culte de saint nicolas a
pris son essor au 12e siècle lorsque les
famines décimé les campagnes européennes
et pour ce spécialiste des contes et
légendes
ce n'est certainement pas un hasard
beaucoup d'historiens pense que l'église
a comment dirais-je a fait connaître
cette histoire pour essayer de mettre en
arrêt à cette anthropophagie qui sévit
c'est vous dire les choses comme elles
sont qui sévit encore dans nos campagnes
dans nos arrières campagne perdue parce
que les temps et déploie de rainures
dans la tradition saint nicolas est
accompagné du père fouettard qui punit
les enfants turbulents
le père fouettard que parfois on appelle
le boucher
[Musique]